nous sommes à bina petit village d'à
peine 700 habitants située dans le loir
et cher
ici pas de collège de nice et de cinéma
de train et encore moins de centre
commercial juste une boulangerie un
restaurant et une église est les
services publics manquent cruellement
alors pour certains binationaux c'est
justement le but recherché vivre dans
une bulle pour d'autres assez bien plus
problématique
moi j'ai l'occasion de bouger pas mal
donc ça va mais je vois mon mari qui a
pas de voitures qui est coincé à la
maison pour l'instant donc oui on peut
rien faire au moins nous on a choisi de
venir à la campagne c'est pas pour avoir
tout sous la main
obligatoirement je conçois tout à fait
que des personnes âgées ou qu'on compass
de moyen de locomotion là c'est un réel
problème vu de ne pas avoir de service
public à proximité
ça oui je le conçois tout à fait c'est
vrai que c'est difficile pour les genres
euros c'est ce que je dis toujours vous
ne pouvez pas vous déplacer dans les
villes ils ont tout ce qu'il faut ils
ont les buts
ils ont tous à proximité nous on est les
derniers roue de la charrette temps nous
nous les gens de la campagne oui on est
des gens à part on a le droit à rien on
n'a pas le droit d'aller prendre le
train on n'a pas de gars là je crois pas
non il n'y a pas eu d or vision biaisée
disons tous non je vois que la tentation
disco house were le marché village
voisin de 2000 habitants il y as presque
tous excepté l'essentiel un médecin le
dernier est parti à la retraite le 20
décembre dernier sans être remplacés en
cas de problème les habitants doivent
parcourir jusqu'à 40 km pour atteindre
les hôpitaux de blois orléans ou encore
châteaudun
c'est pour se faire soigner moi je vais
avant j'allais kilomètres d'ici il est
parti à la retraite aussi et là
maintenant je vais à jouer j'en ai
trouvé un jaune
les gens de duscher d'horaires ils
veulent pas faire d'erreurs commises
ancien médecin de campagne qui était
jour et nuit sur la brèche à les soigner
les gens au fin fond des fermes
peut-être dans les villages mettant les
gens les nouvelles générations il veux
qu'ils aspirent à autre chose il veut le
faire
j'ai pas lutter 12h 14h de ses 18 heures
et après ils veulent partir en week end
et une médecin de nuit je pense que
c'est qu'un prenne d'argent ils sont pas
payés ou la fraude et les inciter à
venir pourquoi pas jeunes médecins le
maître pendant quatre ou cinq ans il ya
posé une région du bout de quatre ou
cinq ans après choisiront ils veulent
comme ça il y aurait jamais eu de
pénurie de médecins dans une région
après je sais pas si c'est faisable ou
pas faisable
ça pourrait être une solution voilà
comme dans l'éducation nationale
au bout de tant d'années après ils ont
droit de choisir où ils veulent pour
pallier à cette absence direction la
seule pharmacie du village où un centre
de télémédecine flambant neuf vient
d'être installé alors un médecin vous
attend derrière cette porte un voile a
donc je vous invite à à rentrer dans cet
espace de téléconsultation donc voilà
vous avez l'écran avec lequel vous allez
rentrer en contact avec le médecin sous
15 minutes d'attentes donc le médecin
peut vous demander très rapidement de
prendre votre tension à l'aide d'objets
connectés l'attention la température
saturation en oxygène est ainsi que le
loto scop pour le l'oreille
là une consultation virtuel qui attire
surtout les personnes âgées dans
l'incapacité de se déplacer
donc c'est fatigue aussi de vos journées
vous n'avez pas l'habitude et vous
restez là bas deux heures trois heures
des habitants qui espère toujours
l'arrivée d'un ou plusieurs
professionnels de santé dans ce bassin
qui regroupe 5000 habitants